raison des restos du coeur ce samedi des
étudiants de l'iut de rambouillet ont
organisé une collecte de produits
d'hygiène pour les bébés au profit des
restos du coeur
accompagnés des bénévoles de
l'association toute la journée ils ont
distribué des flyers et récolter des
produits dans la galerie marchande de
l'hypermarché de la clairière
cette bonne action ne devrait pas être
la dernière dans le cadre de leurs
études ils organiseront d'autres projets
pour aider les restos les précisions au
micro de sephora namani c'est vraiment
important des déchets qui peuvent pas
vraiment se nourrir et en plus ça touche
aussi des jeunes
moi je suivais le cycab de plus en plus
de jeunes qui sont touchés par sa pas
forcément à mon âge moi j'ai giclé 18
ans les verts la vingtaine c'est quand
il y en a beaucoup qui s'ils ont besoin
des restos du coeur
il faut savoir qu'à une boîte de lait ça
coûte très très cher et que quand les
moments sont dans une situation
difficile
la première chose c'est de les aider
pour leur bébé puis c'est quelque chose
qui est important pour leur vie libre
même à elle